[Music]
there's nothing like a good old Disney
movie to lift your spirits especially
one like frozen it's impossible not to
fall in love with this movies many
characters which can make choosing a
favorite ones simply impossible wait
until the end to find out which frozen
character is set to swing the other way
new here don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and give the things a
big thumbs up now are you ready to hear
some shocking frozen to fan theories
[Laughter]
Anna might have powers of her own if
there's one thing that's plagued every
frozen fan brain since the movies
initial release its Elsa's powers while
most people were fine with the fact that
she was gifted with wintery magics
others ask themselves one simple
question where did these powers come
from since it isn't too common for
Disney characters to be born with
abilities we have to wonder why they
exist in Queen Elsa out of all people
some fans believe that the Royal
arendelle bloodline has magics attached
to it but if this is true where are
honest special abilities at the young
princess might be brave beyond belief
but she doesn't seem to exude any powers
of her own unless of course she has yet
to uncover them for herself a popular
fan theory is that frozen 2 will
showcase Ana's powers so what kind of
magical abilities would the ice Queen's
sister possess for the most part fans
believe that Anna could be the exact
opposite of her sister and by this we
mean that she might have fiery magics of
her own this could pose a threat for
Elsa especially if Anna doesn't learn
how to control her powers could a warm
summer be on the horizon for arendelle
we hope not for Olaf's sake
Tarzan Prince of arendelle there is
something special about every single
Disney character however some of these
protagonists beg for extra attention
when Elsa and Anna were young girls
their parents set out to sea and never
returned
this caused them to have to grow up a
lot quicker than normal in the end
having the face of arendelle on their
shoulders was not an easy task
but they may do so what happened to Elsa
and honest
parents you might ask a popular fan
theory is that their boat shipwrecked
leaving them stranded on an island sound
familiar well that's probably because
this is how the Tarzan movie starts
their mother who is pregnant at the time
gave birth to Tarzan on the island while
the theory was debunked for a few years
in a row it was later revealed as
factual so yes Tarzan is Elsa and Anna's
younger brother
this makes Tarzan a prince and Jana
princess by marriage
some fans desperately hope that a family
reunion will occur in frozen 3 which has
yet to be announced or confirmed are you
surprised that these Disney characters
are related
cousin rapunzel rapunzel rapunzel let
down your hair and while you're at it
can you tell us if you're related to
Elsa and Anna if you're a fan of both
tangled and frozen you might have read
that there are many theories tie-in
these two Disney movies together
tangled first hit the big screen in 2010
and left many fans wishing for more so
imagine their surprise when Rapunzel and
Flynn were spotted in the frozen movie
since it isn't too common for Disney
characters to randomly cameo the
internet began to speculate about
possible explanations and this is why
they came up with Rapunzel as Elsa and
Anna's first cousin this theory makes
total sense when you think about it
first of all frozen aired exactly 3
years after tangled in which is when
Elsa and Ana's parents set off to sea
for a wedding our hypothesis is that the
king and queen of arendelle set out to
sea to attend Rapunzel's wedding but
tragically failed to do so does this
make any sense to you or are we just
grasping at straws here there's 20 feet
of fresh powder down there
you're gonna kill her Christophe is
Santa Claus
with so many frozen theories flying
around it can be hard to believe every
single one of them this is especially
true because some tend to contradict the
ones that came before them if there's
one fan theory we simply can't get over
it's that one that ties Kristoff in
Santa Claus together there are many
reasons why the internet would believe
that these two characters are one in the
same and they aren't as far-fetched as
you might think
did you ever find it strange that
Christoph's best friend is a reindeer
well you might not have said it out loud
but surely you were thinking it not only
does Kristoff love reindeer but he also
rides a sleigh but training a group of
flying reindeer can take time to master
on top of all this Kristoff was raised
by trolls which some might say have a
lot in common with elves not convinced
well hold your horses there's more
coming your way
Kristoff is also a huge fan of snow and
probably has the rosiest cheeks we've
ever seen lastly his name could easily
abbreviate to Chris which is said to
cause his first name wait if Kristoff is
Santa Claus
does that make Anna miss Claus Olaf will
become human
Olaf is one of the most interesting
characters in frozen especially since he
seems to be a magical snowman of some
sorts while some might speculate that
Elsa's subconscious created Olaf when
she needed a friend
the Internet would beg to differ fans
have concocted a new theory and it's
definitely adorable
some believe that Olaf is actually a
human being however he was cursed into
becoming a snowman for the rest of his
life although fated to be like this
forever Elsa's love for him might just
be enough to set him free a widespread
theory is that frozen - will tell the
tale of Olaf and Elsa's love story the
fact that Elsa didn't have a love
interest in frozen has caused the
Internet to go wild with theories after
all it isn't every day that a queen can
rule without a king well this is a
modern-day Disney film people so get
used to the idea would you be happy with
this couple coming to life if not let us
know if you think there's a better
alternative The Snow Queen it's only
normal for people to draw inspiration
from old fables after all this is how
popular Disney movies like Mulan and
Pocahontas came to be so why would
frozen be any different else's character
was loosely based on the Snow Queen
which is an original story by Hans
Christian Andersen while this story is
actually told in seven parts the same
can't be said about Disney's
interpretation of it some fans were a
little peeved by the fact that frozen
didn't stay true to the Snow Queen
storyline but they might be lighting
their torches a little too quickly some
fans believe that frozen too will come
back to its roots and make the Snow
Queen proud should this theory be true
we might be introduced to an evil mirror
that could cause a rift between Anna and
Elsa the fact that frozen is based off
this fairy tale doesn't technically mean
that both stories have to end and begin
on the same note this is especially true
giving the ugly nature mini fairy tales
uphold after all we want Elsa and Anna
to live happily ever after
do we not uncle Jack Frost it shouldn't
come as a surprise to hear that frozen
is one of the most well-received Disney
movies of all time after all millions of
people have flooded the movie theaters
to catch its original release what makes
the musical masterpiece so endearing is
its refreshing take on relationships
frozen highlights the importance of
family and friendship which is a first
family might be an important theme in
frozen but the royal bloodline wasn't
showcased in the slightest and the
origin of Elsa's powers weren't made
public either since Disney left us all
in the dark the public thought it was
wise to make up assumptions of their own
a celebrated internet theory is one of
Queen Garda being Jack Frost's little
sister this would basically mean that
Jack Frost is Elsa and Anna's uncle
while this theory is highly improbable
due to Queen Garda and Jack Frost being
from two different universes internet
fans don't believe it to be impossible
in the end this relationship would
explain where Elsa got her powers from
would you be shocked to see uncle frost
making an appearance in frozen 2 we sure
wouldn't the big bad trolls every movie
needs a villain after all a
straightforward storyline has little
appeal for a Disney movie to captivate
its audience it needs to be riddled with
a handful of troubling obstacle
it's sort of hard for Heroes to prove
just how brave and selfless they can be
it's safe to say that frozen's villain
took us all by surprise the adorable
Huns never once seemed like the
backstabbing type this has caused many
frozen fans to wonder if there might be
something more to the story as many of
you know the trolls have the power to
change a person's intentions and some
people believe that Hans mind and heart
were toyed with during Ana's absence
could this mean that the trolls will
show their true colors in frozen -
should this be the case there's no
telling what will happen to the kingdom
of arendelle
after all the trolls were the ones who
told Elsa's parents to keep her powers
hidden did you ever wonder how Hans
found out about Elsa's powers in the
first place something smells fishy to us
and surely were not the only ones who
can smell it
Elsa's upbringing as Voltaire once said
with great power comes great
responsibility it's a lesson that Elsa
put into practice very early on when
Elsa first realized that she had the
ability to create snow and ice the first
person she wanted to confide in was her
little sister Anna at the time however
Elsa's powers were too strong to control
which resulted in her nearly killing her
baby sister since magic can spook the
common folk the king and queen of
arendelle saw fit to keep their eldest
daughter locked away a popular internet
theory is that else's mom and dad
weren't as innocent as they lead on
after all they did have some curious
material hidden in their castle do you
remember when Hans imprisoned and
chained Elsa in the arendelle dungeons
if so you might have asked yourself how
he fabricated chains that could prevent
Elsa's powers from escaping the only
explanation is that Elsa's parents had
these chains made when she was just a
little girl
her powers are what make her so unique
it's clear that her parents were afraid
of who she'd one day become but
obviously they were wrong and thinking
that she'd be anything short of
extraordinary Elsa is a lesbian it's
only normal for Disney movies to include
different types of characters into their
storylines
however Disney has yet to put a gay
character as a lead for some people the
idea of Elsa being a lesbian makes
little sense but
others it's a revelation since it is
highly uncommon for a Disney princess to
become queen of anything without a king
by her side some fans have started
asking questions while most Disney
movies end with happily ever afters Elsa
did not get married or find love at the
end of frozen despite the fact that she
had little time for love during her epic
journey of self-discovery the internet
believes this to be all the proof they
need
so if Elsa's really a lesbian who's her
lover going to be disney has announced
that all frozen characters will be
present in frozen too however there will
be an additional two characters
introduced into the plot could the
character voice by actress Evan Rachel
would be else's future lover if so we'll
only get the details when this movie
hits the big screen in 2019 so are you
on Team Olaf or team Evan let us know
which couple you'd like to see in frozen
2 in the comments
we hope these frozen two theories lived
up to your wildest expectations thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]